Durant la pause, plusieurs personnes m'ont demandé
mon avis sur le débat sur le vieillissement.
Et ceci sera mon unique commentaire à ce sujet.
Et c'est que, je comprends
que les optimistes vivent plus longtemps que les pessimistes.
(Rires)
Ce dont je vais vous parler pendant mes 18 minutes c'est
le fait que nous sommes sur le point de passer de la lecture du code génétique
aux premières étapes du début
de l'écriture du code nous-même.
Cela ne fait que 10 ans ce mois-ci
depuis notre publication de la première séquence
d'un organisme doué de vie indépendante,
celle de haemophilus influenzae.
Cela a pris un projet génome
de 13 ans réduit a 4 mois.
Nous pouvons à présent reproduire le même projet génome
en à peu près
2 à 8 heures
Donc durant la dernière décennie, un grand nombre de génomes ont été ajoutés:
la majorité des pathogènes humains,
quelques plantes,
plusieurs insectes et plusieurs mammifères,
dont le génome humain.
La génomique au stade de réflexion
d'il y a un peu plus de 10 ans
prévoyait qu'à la fin de cet année, nous aurions
séquencé de 3 à 5 génomes;
c'est de l'ordre de plusieurs centaines.
Nous venons juste d'obtenir une bourse de la Gordon et Betty Moore Foundation
pour séquencer 130 génomes cette année,
comme un projet secondaire pour des organismes écologiques
Donc le rythme de lecture du code génétique a changé.
Mais à mesure que l'on cherche, ce qui se trouve ailleur,
nous avons à peine gratté la surface
sur ce qui est disponible sur la planète.
La plupart des gens ne s'en rendent pas compte, parce qu'ils sont invisibles,
mais les microbes représentent environ la moitié de la biomasse terrestre,
alors que tous les animaux ne représentent qu'environ
1 millième de toute la biomasse.
Et peut-être que c'est quelque chose que les gens d'Oxford ne font pas si souvent,
mais si jamais vous allez à la mer,
et que vous avalez une gorgée d'eau de mer,
gardez en tête que chaque millilitre
contient environ un million de bactéries
et de l'ordre de 10 millions de virus.
Moins de 5000 espèces de microbes
ont été définis il y a 2 ans,
et donc nous avons décidé de faire quelque chose à ce sujet.
Et nous avons lancé l'Expédition Sorceler II,
au cours de laquelle nous avons, comme pour toute grande expédition océanographique,
essayer de prendre un échantillon tous les 300 kilomètres.
Nous avons commencé dans les Bermudes pour notre projet test.
Puis nous sommes montés jusqu'à Halifax,
longeant la côte Est des États-Unis,
la mer des Caraïbes, le canal de Panamá,
vers les Galápagos, puis tout le long du Pacifique,
et nous sommes maintenant en train de cheminer
à travers l'Océan Indien.
C'est un tâche très difficile; nous le faisons sur un bateau à voile,
en partie pour motiver les jeunes
à faire de la science.
Les expériences sont incroyablement simples.
Nous prenons tout simplement de l'eau de mer et nous la filtrons,
et nous collectons des organismes de tailles différentes sur des filtres différents.
Et ensuite nous ramenons leur ADN à notre labo à Rockville,
où nous pouvons séquencer 100 millions de lettres
du code génétique toutes les 24 heures.
Et en faisant ainsi,
nous avons fait des découvertes incroyables.
Par exemple, on pensait que les pigments visuels
dans nos yeux -- il n'y avait qu' 1 ou 2 organismes
dans l'environnement ayant les mêmes pigments.
Il s'avère que presque toutes les espèces
dans les parties supérieures de l'océan
dans les régions chaudes du monde
ont les même photorécepteurs,
et utilisent le soleil comme source de leur énergie
et de leur communication.
Sur un site, dans un baril d'eau de mer,
nous avons découvert 1,3 millions de nouveaux gènes
et jusqu'à 50 000 nouvelles espèces.
Nous avons étendu le projet à l'air
cette fois-ci avec une bourse de la Sloan Foundation.
Nous sommes en train de mesurer combien de virus et de bactéries
chacun d'entre nous inspire et expire chaque jour,
en particulier dans les avions
ou les auditoriums fermés
(Rires)
Nous filtrons à travers des appareils simples;
nous pouvons amasser de l'ordre d'un milliard de microbes en un seul jour
en filtrant au sommet d'un immeuble de la ville de New York.
Et nous sommes en train de séquencer tout ça
en ce moment.
Juste du côté de la collecte des données,
juste où nous en sommes dans les Galápagos,
nous trouvons actuellement que presque tous les 300 kilomètres,
nous constatons une diversité phénoménale
dans nos échantillons de l'océan.
Certains semblent être logique
en termes de gradients de températures différents.
Donc voici une photo satellite
basée sur les températures--rouge étant chaud,
bleu étant froid --
et nous constatons une différence énorme entre
les échantillons d'eaux chaudes et les échantillons d'eaux froides,
en termes d'abondance d'espèces.
L'autre chose qui nous a un peu pris par surprise
c'est que ces photorécepteurs détectent tous des longueurs d'ondes du spectre visible différentes,
et nous pouvons le prédire en nous basant sur leurs séquences d'acides aminés.
Et cela varie considérablement de région en région.
Ce n'est donc pas surprenant que
dans l'océan profond, où l'eau est principalement bleu,
les photorécepteurs ont tendance à voir la lumière bleue.
Quand il y a beaucoup de chlorophylle dans les alentours,
ils voient beaucoup de lumière verte.
Mais ils varient encore plus,
s'étendant possiblement jusqu'à l'infrarouge et l’ultraviolet
dans les cas extrêmes.
Juste pour essayer de faire un bilan
de l'ampleur de notre répertoire de gènes,
nous avons assemblé toutes les données--
en incluant toutes celles de l'expédition pour l'instant,
ce qui représente plus de la moitié de toutes les données de gènes sur la planète--
et cela totalisait environ 29 millions de gènes.
Et nous avons essayé de les ranger en familles de gènes
pour voir ce que représentait ces découvertes:
Découvrons-nous de nouveaux membres de familles déjà connues,
ou découvrons-nous de nouvelles familles?
Et il s'avère que nous avons environ 50 000
familles de gènes majeures,
mais chaque nouvel échantillon que nous prélevons dans l'environnement
s'ajoute de façon linéaire à ces nouvelles familles.
Donc nous sommes à une étape précoce de découverte
des gènes de base,
des composants et de la vie sur cette planète.
Quand on regarde le soit-disant arbre phylogénétique,
nous sommes au coin supérieur droit avec les animaux.
Parmi ces 29 millions de gènes environ,
nous n'en avons qu'environ 24 000
dans notre génome.
Et si vous prenez tout l'ensemble des animaux,
nous en partageons probablement moins de 30 000
et probablement peut-être une douzaine
ou plus de milliers de familles de gènes différentes.
Je vois maintenant que ces gènes
ne sont pas seulement les éléments de conception de l'évolution.
Et nous avons une façon de penser très axée sur les gènes --
pour en revenir peut-être aux idées de Richard Dawkins--
plutôt qu'axée sur le génome,
qui représente différentes structures de ces composants géniques.
L'ADN synthétique, la capacité de synthétiser l'ADN,
a changé en quelque sorte au même rythme
que celui du séquençage de l'ADN
ces 1 à 2 dernières décennies,
et est en train de devenir très rapide et beaucoup moins cher.
Notre première pensée au sujet de la génomique synthétique nous est venue
alors que nous séquencions le deuxième génome en 1995,
celui du mycoplasma genitalium.
Et nous avons des T-Shirts très sympas qui lisaient,
vous savez, "J'aime mon genitalium".
Il ne s'agit qu'en fait d'un microorganisme.
Mais il a grossièrement 500 gènes.
Haemophilus avait 1 800 gènes.
Et nous avons simplement posé la question,
si une espèce en a besoin de 800, une autre de 500,
y-a-t-il un plus petit ensemble de gènes
qui pourrait correspondre à un système d'exploitation minimal?
Donc nous avons commencé à faire des mutagenèses de transposons.
Les transposons sont tout simplement de petits brins d'ADN
qui sont aléatoirement introduits dans le code génétique.
Et s'ils s'introduisent au milieu d'un gène, ils perturbent sa fonction.
Donc nous avons fait une plan de tous les gènes
qui pouvaient endurer des insertions de transposons
et nous les avons appelé "gènes non-essentiels."
Mais il s'avère que l’environnement joue un rôle crucial dans ce cas,
et vous ne pouvez que
définir un gène essentiel ou un gène non-essentiel
en fonction de ce qu'il y a dans l'environnement.
Nous avons aussi essayé de prendre une approche intellectuellement plus directe
avec les génomes de 13 organismes apparentés,
et nous les avons tous comparés, pour voir ce qu'ils avaient en commun.
et nous obtenons ces cercles se chevauchants. Et nous trouvons seulement 173 gènes
commun à tous les 13 organismes.
Ce pool génique s'étend un peu si nous ignorons
un parasite intracellulaire;
il s'étend encore plus
quand nous nous focalisons sur les ensembles de gènes fondamentaux
de 310 et quelques.
Donc nous pensons pouvoir étendre
ou contracter les génomes, ici ça dépend du point de vue,
de possiblement entre 300 et 400 gènes
à partir du minimum de 500.
Le seul moyen de prouver ces idées
était de construire un chromosome artificiel avec ces gènes à l'intérieur,
et nous avons dû faire ça sous forme de cassettes.
Nous avons découvert que synthétiser avec précision de l'ADN
en grands morceaux était extrêmement difficile.
Ham Smith et Clyde Hutchinson, mes collègues là-dessus,
ont développé une nouvelle méthode passionnante
qui nous a permis de synthétiser un virus ayant 5 000 paires de bases
en seulement 2 semaines
qui était 100 % précise,
en termes de sa séquence et de sa biologie.
C'était une expérience assez excitante -- quand nous avons simplement pris le morceau d'ADN synthétique,
l'avons injecté dans la bactérie et tout à coup,
cet ADN a commencé à lancer la production de particules virales
qui ont tourné autour et ensuite tué la bactérie.
Celui-ci n'était pas le premier virus synthétique--
un poliovirus avait été fabriqué un an auparavant--
mais il n'était qu'un dixième de milliers de fois aussi actif
et a pris 3 ans à faire.
Ceci est un dessin de la structure de Phi X-174.
Ceci est un cas où le logiciel construit maintenant son propre support matériel,
et c'est les notions que nous retrouvons en biologie.
Les gens parlent aussitôt de guerre biologique,
et j'ai récemment témoigné devant le Sénat,
et un comité spécial que le gouvernement Américain a mis en place
pour étudier ce domaine.
Et je pense qu'il est important de garder la réalité à l'esprit,
contre ce qu'il se passe dans l'imagination des gens.
En gros, n'importe quel virus qui a été séquencé jusqu'à aujourd'hui--
ce génome peut être fabriqué.
Et immédiatement les gens paniquent au sujet d'Ebola ou de la variole,
mais l'ADN de ces organismes n'est pas infectieux.
Donc même si quelqu'un venait à fabriquer le génome du virus de la variole,
cet ADN lui-même ne causerait pas d'infections.
La seule véritable inquiétude qu'ont les départements de sécurité
concerne les virus sur mesure.
Et il n'existe que 2 pays, les États-Unis et ce qui était autrefois l'Union Soviétique,
qui ont fait des efforts majeurs
pour essayer de créer des agents de guerre biologique.
Si cette recherche a réellement été abandonnée,
il devrait y avoir très peu d'activité
basé sur le savoir-faire requis pour fabriquer des virus sur mesure dans le futur.
Je pense que les organismes unicellulaires sont possibles dans 2 ans.
Et peut-être les cellules eucaryotes,
celles qui nous composent,
sont possibles pour cette décennie.
Donc nous fabriquons actuellement plusieurs douzaines de structures différentes,
parce que nous pouvons varier les cassettes et les gènes
qui sont insérés dans ce chromosome artificiel.
La clé est, comment mettons-nous tous les autres?
Nous commençons avec ces segments,
et ensuite nous avons un système de recombinaison homologue
qui les réassemblent en un chromosome.
Une technique dérivée d'un organisme, deinococcus radiodurans,
qui peut prendre 3 millions de rads de radiations et ne pas mourir.
Il réassemble son génome après cette rafale radioactive
en environ 12 à 24 heures,
après que ses chromosomes aient été complètement déchiquetés.
Cet organism est omniprésent sur la planète,
et existe peut-être maintenant
dans l'espace à cause de tous nos voyages interstellaires.
Ceci est un bécher en verre après
environ ½ million de rads de radiation.
Ce verre a commencé à brûler et à craquer,
pendant que les microbes assis au fond
sont devenus de plus en plus heureux.
Voici une image de ce qui se passe:
en haut on voit le génome
après 1.7 million de rads de radiation.
le chromosome est complètement déchiqueté.
Et voici ce même ADN se réassemblant automatiquement
24 heures plus tard.
C'est vraiment stupéfiant que ces organismes puissent faire ça,
et nous avons probablement des milliers,
si ce n'est des dizaines de milliers d'espèces différentes
sur cette planète qui sont capables de faire ça.
Une fois que ces génomes sont synthétisés,
la première étape consiste simplement à les transplanter
dans une cellule sans génome.
Donc nous pensons que les cellules synthétiques vont avoir un énorme potentiel,
pas seulement dans la compréhension des bases de la biologie
mais aussi, espérons-le, en termes de questions écologiques et sociétales.
Par exemple, à partir du troisième organisme que nous avons séquencé,
Methanococcus jannaschii: il vit à des températures équivalentes à l'eau bouillante,
sa source d'énergie est l'hydrogène
et tout son carbone vient du CO2 qu'il récupère dans l'environnement.
Donc nous connaissons beaucoup de processus différents,
des milliers d'organismes différents à présent
qui vivent sur le CO2,
et qui peuvent le capturer en retour.
Donc au lieu d'utiliser le carbone du pétrole
pour des procédés synthétiques,
nous avons l'occasion d'utiliser le carbone
et de le récupérer de l'atmosphère,
le convertissant en biopolymères
et autres produits.
Nous avons un organisme qui vit sur le monoxyde de carbone,
et que nous utilisons comme puissance réductrice
pour scinder l'eau pour produire de l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène.
Aussi, il existe de nombreux processus
qui peuvent être conçus pour métaboliser le méthane.
Et DuPont a un programme important avec Statoil en Norvège
qui consiste à capturer et convertir le méthane
des champs de gaz qui existent là-bas en produits utiles.
Dans peu de temps, je pense qu'il va y avoir une nouvelle discipline
appelé la Génomique Combinatoire,
parce qu'avec ces nouvelles capacités de synthèse,
ces vastes répertoires d'arrangements de gènes
et de recombinaison homologue,
nous pensons pouvoir créer un robot pour faire
peut-être un million de chromosomes différents par jour.
Et donc, comme avec toute biologie,
on obtient une sélection à travers un filtrage,
que vous filtriez pour la production d'hydrogène,
ou la production d'un produit chimique, ou seulement la viabilité.
Comprendre le rôle de ces gènes
va être à notre portée.
Nous sommes en train d'essayer de modifier la photosynthèse
pour produire de l'hydrogène via la lumière solaire.
La photosynthèse est modulée par l'oxygène,
et nous avons une hydrogénase insensible à l'oxygène
qui selon nous va totalement changer ce processus.
Nous combinons aussi des cellulases,
les enzymes qui décomposent les sucres complexes en sucres simples
et la fermentation dans la même cellule
pour produire de l'éthanol.
La production pharmaceutique est déjà en cours
dans les grands laboratoires
ayant recours à des microbes.
La chimie des composants dans l'environnement
est d'un niveau de complexité vastement supérieur
à celle que nos meilleurs chimistes arrivent à produire.
Je pense que de futures espèces modifiées
pourraient devenir une source de nourriture,
avec un peu de chance une source d'énergie,
un remède pour l'environnement
et peut-être
un remplacement pour l'industrie pétrochimique.
Laissez-moi juste terminer avec les études éthiques et politiques.
Nous avons retardé le début de nos expériences en 1999
jusqu'à ce que nous puissions compléter un an et demi de rapport d'enquête bioéthique
sur si nous devrions essayer de fabriquer des espèces artificielles.
Chacune des grandes religions y a participé.
En fait c'était une étude très étrange,
parce que les différents leaders religieux utilisaient chacun leurs Saintes Écritures comme livres de lois,
et ils ne trouvaient rien qui interdisait de créer de la vie,
donc ça doit être bon. Finalement les seules inquiétudes
se concentraient sur l'idée de guerre biologique associé à la chose,
mais ils nous ont permis de commencer ces expériences
pour les raisons pour lesquelles nous étions en train de les faire.
A présent la Sloan Foundation vient juste de financer
une étude multi-institutionelle sur la question,
pour mettre au point les risques et les bénéfices pour la société,
et les règles que les équipes scientifiques comme la notre
doivent suivre dans ce domaine,
et nous essayons de donner le bon exemple au fur et à mesure que nous avançons.
Ce sont des problèmes complexes.
Excepté pour la menace du bio-terrorisme,
Ce sont de problèmes simples du genre,
pouvons nous fabriquer des choses pour produire de l'énergie propre,
peut-être révolutionnant
ce que les pays développés peuvent faire
et les fournir à travers de simples procédés.
Merci beaucoup.